[Music]
hi I'm poppy do you like being famous
Oh what the hell's going on
am i dead you're on a show inside that
person's telephone hello this is Neil
that's a pretty pretty cellular
telephone do you want to be more famous
why would I want to be more famous I'm
already really really famous I have to
do is say things people want to hear and
then people will retweet you okay yeah I
can do that seems easy people like it
when you say chicken sandwich a lot
chicken sandwich chicken sandwich mmm
delicious delicious chicken sandwiches
chicken sandwich
you said chicken sandwich too that's
great
they also like it when you say delicious
sauce I like that I'm going to tweet
that now delicious eyes going viral
poppy a going viral poppy I'm going
viral poppy I'm going viral poppy I'm
going viral poppy I'm going viral Bobby
I'm going my roll let it flow through
you Tom Green I feel it inside of me
poppy the throbbing pose of the internet
flowing through my veins you living
the internet flows through us all